ahora vamos a hablar de la mágica
república de finlandia un país muy
simple que por supuesto no existe en el
mundo real pero nos va a servir para
hacer un modelo como regularmente
hacemos en economía supongamos que
finlandia puede producir dos bienes
pesas y barras energéticas o una
combinación de ambos vamos a trazar su
curva de posibilidades de producción o
cpp también la podemos llamar frontera
de posibilidades de producción o fp
trazamos dos ejes uno para las pesas y
otro para las barras energéticas y vamos
a suponer que todo lo que hacemos es en
miles de toneladas por año en el eje
vertical tenemos 1 2 3 4 y 5 y en el eje
horizontal tenemos mil dos mil tres mil
y cuatro mil y cinco mil toneladas por
año ponemos las pesas en el eje vertical
y las barras energéticas en el eje
horizontal imaginemos que somos el
ministro de economía o el secretario de
comercio de finlandia y sabemos que si
ponemos toda la energía del país en la
producción de pesas y distribuimos de
manera eficiente todos nuestros recursos
podemos producir 4
toneladas de pesas por año también
sabemos que si queremos producir barras
energéticas tendremos que disminuir
nuestra producción de pesas entre más
barras energéticas produzcamos
produciremos menos pesas si usamos todos
los recursos que tenemos de la manera
más eficiente produciremos 3000 barras
energéticas por año y obtendremos esta
curva esta es nuestra curva de
posibilidades de producción si el país
opera con eficiencia y utiliza todos sus
recursos cuando hablo de recursos me
refiero al tiempo que trabaja la gente y
las fábricas que se utilizan plenamente
así como también al uso eficiente de la
tierra o los materiales entonces
estaremos situados en algún punto sobre
esta curva que también se conoce como
frontera de posibilidades de producción
porque no podemos sobrepasar su límite a
no ser que algo cambie vamos a mostrar
algunos ejemplos de por qué cambia si el
país hace un uso eficiente de sus
recursos puede elegir situarse en
distintos puntos de esta curva a este
punto le llamaremos eficiente pero esto
es una eficiencia teórica porque en la
práctica ningún país puede utilizar
plenamente todos sus recursos
la gente no trabaja absolutamente todo
el tiempo por ejemplo entonces en
realidad un país puede situarse un poco
por debajo de su curva de posibilidades
de producción pero imaginemos que en
teoría nuestro país es capaz de alguna
manera de operar muy eficientemente y
está situado en su frontera de
posibilidades de producción ahora
supongamos que entra en algún tipo de
recesión en la que de pronto una parte
de su población deja de trabajar si no
está utilizando plenamente su fuerza
laboral qué pasa con su producción bien
pues su producción se desplazará hacia
abajo de la curva produciríamos en este
punto que llamaremos desempleo y nos
desplazaremos porque el desempleo es un
uso ineficiente de los recursos tal vez
finlandia le declaró la guerra a otro
país y ese otro país destruyó una parte
de su capacidad productiva por ejemplo
algunas fábricas o tal vez algunas
personas simplemente decidieron irse a
otro lugar qué pasaría entonces la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
se contrae porque si tenemos menos
fábricas o si nuestra población
disminuye
o si perdemos territorio a manos de
otros países nos quedamos con menos
recursos para producir y podemos
terminar en un escenario donde la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
se contrae de esta manera este
desplazamiento de la curva de
posibilidades de producción tiene lugar
cuando los recursos se reducen y por
supuesto ningún país quiere estar en
esta situación todos quieren tener un
crecimiento económico el crecimiento
económico ocurre cuando un país expande
sus recursos entonces como podemos
colocarnos por encima de la frontera de
posibilidades de producción o establecer
una frontera que esté más lejana
supongamos que queremos una frontera de
posibilidades de producción como ésta no
es necesario incrementar
proporcionalmente ambos bienes pero como
podemos obtenerla existen dos maneras la
primera es incrementar el capital y qué
queremos decir con capital en este
ejemplo nos referimos a invertir en la
creación de más fábricas o tal vez
obtener mejores tecnologías como
herramientas asistidas por computadora o
robots que nos permitan aumentar la
producción de barras energéticas o pesas
por año la otra
posibilidad es incrementar la población
en especial la población que puede
trabajar la clave es que la curva o la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
de un país es la combinación de bienes
que puede producir en un determinado
intervalo de tiempo utilizando todos sus
recursos de una manera totalmente
eficiente si el país entre en algún tipo
de recesión o no utilice eficientemente
sus recursos va a colocarse en un punto
por debajo de su frontera de
posibilidades de producción al ir
saliendo de la recesión irá acercándose
nuevamente a ella ahora bien la frontera
de posibilidades de producción se
contrae cuando los recursos de un país
se reducen por ejemplo si destruyen sus
fábricas en la guerra o si una parte de
su población emigra también puede
expandirse cuando aumenta la población
que puede trabajar para producir más
bienes o cuando hay más capital más
fábricas más tierra más materiales para
producir más bienes y eso es lo que
todos los países quieren entonces cuando
nos referimos al crecimiento económico
estamos hablando de ampliar la frontera
de posibilidad
desde producción nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo